(violin music)
- What the (bleep)?
- Oh my god, what?
- It's Drew.
He just posted a picture on
Facebook with him and some girl.
- No way.
Y'all just broke up.
- Yeah, it's definitely
been less than a month.
- Total (bleep) asshole.
- How has he found someone already?
I've only been on one date.
That's totally unfair.
And that's not even his type.
- And how did it get so many likes?
- Should I go out and take
a picture with a dude?
- You should like the picture.
Like it.
- Uh...
- Wait.
We don't even know if
he's dating the girl.
- We're jumping to conclusions.
(bang)
- He's looking away from her.
- But his hand could be rubbing her back.
- You can't tell.
Her knees are facing him.
- I see boredom in his eyes.
- No conclusive results.
- Maybe just a quick look at her page?
(whooshing)
(upbeat drum music)
- No results.
- Except they thing this is an ear.
Damn it.
- Wait.
Are we being creepy?
Maybe we should stop.
- Girl, no.
This is normal.
- Yeah.
You're right, yeah.
- [Both] We've gotta go deeper.
(bang)
(fast paced drum music)
- What about the trip to Cabo?
- We've already been over the Cabo trip.
It's a dead end.
- But there are links into his
trip to Cabo, two years ago,
I know there are.
- It doesn't make sense anymore.
- This can't be the end of the road.
- I'm sorry, but it is.
I quit the case.
- You can't quit.
- Yes, I have to.
- No, please, I need you.
I can't lose you.
- I can't do this (crying).
(pleading and crying)
- Don't give up.
(ding)
- Drew's updated.
- Oh my god.
(upbeat drum music)
- She has a boyfriend.
- Mhm.
- He hasn't found love yet.
I'm still ahead.
(laughing)
- Yes, girl.
- Not that it matters, of course.
- Of course not.
I mean, you'd be totally happy for him
in a mature and classy kind of way
even if he was dating somebody.
- Yeah.
Obviously.
(bouncy string and horn music)
- We better get going.
We've gotta get these suits back by four.
- Oh, right.
You know we're getting
really good at this.
- I know.
(whooshing)
(creaking)